Thank you for coming over to our Fiscal Year 2010 Full Year...
...and Fourth Quarter Financial Results presentation.
Today, we would like to cover fiscal year 2010 full year...
...as well as the fourth quarter opening results and the key highlights of each business.
As you know, Rakuten has been executing a quite unique business model...
...compared with our competitors.
Leveraging our Internet media and traffic, and implemented retail business...
...and finance business in a very good combination.
And I think we are the only group company which has both retail and finance...
...among the many, many Internet companies.
So, let's go to the numbers.
Here are the highlights.
This was the highest levels of sales and profits in Rakuten's history.
We have three segments: Internet services, finance services, and others.
As for Internet services are concerned,...
...sales grew 25.1% YoY,...
...EBITDA grew 16.8% YoY,...
...ordinary profit grew 15.3% YoY.
For the group total, regardless of the fact that our finance business struggled a little bit...
...still sales grew 16.1%,...
...EBITDA  grew 11.8%, ordinary profit grew 13.5%,...
...so it was a very good fiscal year for us.